أصبحت الفتاة البالغة من العمر 16 عامًا واحدة من
أكثر الوجوه شهرة في إيران
يوم 20 سبتمبر / أيلول ، كانت نيكا
شخصية بارزة في الاحتجاجات ،
وشخصية معروفة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وقفت على صناديق القمامة وهي تهتف للحشود
ويقول المسؤولون إنها ستكون في غضون 24 ساعة.
انضمت نيكا ميتة إلى قائمة متزايدة من
الشابات اللائي فقدن أرواحهن في
الأسابيع الأخيرة حيث اجتاحت الاحتجاجات إيران
وشنت السلطات حملة عنيفة
رداً على
ذلك ، قدمت الحكومة الإيرانية سلسلة من
الادعاءات المتغيرة أولاً قائلة إن موتها لم
يقتبس من أي صلة.  إلى الاحتجاجات
لكنها ألقيت من سطح ، ثم
يوم الأربعاء ادعاء جديد من
القضاء بأنه انتحار على
أساس تحقيقنا باستخدام أكثر من 50
مقطع فيديو من تلك الليلة والتحدث إلى
من معهم في ذلك المساء يمكن لـ CNN أن
تكشف عن ذلك  قضيت بعض ساعات نيكا الأخيرة
في الاحتجاجات بما في ذلك
الأدلة التي تشير إلى أنها تعرضت للمطاردة
والاحتجاز من قبل الأمن قبل ساعات قليلة من
إعلان الدولة أنها
الفيديوهات الأولى التي وجدناها لـ Nika في
20 هنا في الساعة 7 مساءً
حيث تشتعل الاحتجاجات ، يمكن رؤية Nika
مباشرة في المقدمة وهي ترمي الحجارة على
تشكيل من الضباط الذين يرتدون الزي الرسمي
، وقد أدرك بسهولة أنها كانت شجاعة ولا حتى
قال شهود عيان خائفون
في هذه المرحلة في  مساءًا ، تأتي نيكا
هنا بجوار Lale Park
ثم مع وصول المزيد من الضباط ،
يقول شهود إن نيكا تبدأ في الابتعاد عنهم
أولاً على طول شارع keshavaz Boulevard ثم
شارع danversal shirazi حيث
شوهدت وهي تجري مكالمة هاتفية قبل الساعة 8 مساءً بقليل
مع حلول الظلام ، تشتد حملة الشرطة.
في موقع نيكا الجديد ،
بدأت تظهر أدلة على الإصابات ،
وشوهد المحتجون وهم يحتجزون على
ما يبدو من قبل ضباط يرتدون ملابس مدنية ،
قال أحدهم لشبكة CNN إنهم رأوا
قوات الأمن تضرب النساء وتضعهن في
شاحنات الشرطة
في خضم هذا العنف المتزايد.
في
وسط الاحتجاج الساعة 8 و 37 مساءً
وآخر فيديو معروف لها
[موسيقى]
لا تتحرك لا تتحرك تصرخ  كانت
تنحني بين السيارات للاختباء من
السلطات ، حيث قال الشخص الذي يصور من السيارة لشبكة CNN
أنه بعد ذلك بوقت قصير ، تم أخذ نيكا من
قبل العديد من قوات الأمن ذات الجسم الضخم
ووضعها في شاحنة
عند هذه النقطة في المساء ، حيث كانت الشرطة في
كل مكان مقاطع فيديو حددناها جغرافيًا
إلى  مشهد يظهر الشرطة إلى الجنوب
وأيضًا إلى شمال نيكا ، فهذا يعني أنه عندما
كانت تجلس في حركة المرور كانت
محاطة تمامًا
في صباح اليوم التالي ، ستكون ميتة
وفقًا لشهادة الوفاة هذه
التي حصلت عليها لأول مرة بواسطة BBC Persian وتم
التحقق منها بواسطة CNN والتي تظهر أنها  توفيت متأثرة
بجروح متعددة ناجمة عن
اصطدامها بجسم صلب ، ومؤرخة في
21 سبتمبر / أيلول
، لم تعلم عائلة بانيكا
بوفاتها لمدة 10 أيام أخرى ، في حين
قالت والدة نيكا وعمتها في
مقابلات أن مصادر موثوقة
أخبرتهم أنه لأيام خلال تلك النافذة.
كان نيكو محتجزًا لدى الدولة
، وقد أصدرت السلطات الإيرانية
لقطات CCTV هذه مدعية أن نيكا ماتت
بعد رميها من هذا المبنى  في وقت لاحق
من نفس الليلة في حادثة قالوا إنها
غير مرتبطة بالاحتجاجات ،
لم يدعوا أي شخص يُزعم أنه ألقى
بها ولا يمكن لـ CNN التحقق من أن الشخص هو
Nika ولا في اليوم الذي تم فيه تصويره
، عارضت والدة Nika علنًا هذه
اللقطات قائلة إنها ليست ابنتها و
من الصعب التوفيق بين هذه المسيرة الهادئة
والأدلة التي لدينا على أن نيكا
مطاردة من قبل الشرطة واحتجازها قبل ساعات قليلة فقط
لم يرد المسؤولون الإيرانيون على
تحقيق سي إن إن فيما إذا كانت
محتجزة في الساعات التي سبقت
وفاتها.
من المؤكد أن نيكا كان
ناشطًا بارزًا في مركز
حملة الشرطة على الاحتجاج في تلك
الليلة
سي إن إن لندن